vi siete mai chiesti Quali sono le paure
più comuni per gli esseri umani
quando faccio queste domande le risposte
afferiscono spesso a tipo la paura di
volare la paura dei topi dei ragni del
buio dei serpenti
per qualcuno anche del matrimonio
in realtà sul podio delle paure
principali troviamo la glossofobia che è
un termine tecnico per indicare la paura
di parlare in pubblico
Ebbene sì tra gli eventi più
paralizzanti e scatenanti quella parte
del nostro cervello responsabile di far
poi partire tutta una serie di reazioni
a catena a stimoli di paura o minaccia
c'è proprio l'essere su un palco come me
in questo momento
oppure in qualsiasi altra situazione in
cui vi siate trovati e che dovevate
alzarvi parlare davanti a un gruppo
farvi ascoltare e comprendere
e le ricerche ci dicono
che il 75% della popolazione ha paura di
parlare in pubblico Chi è che di voi ha
paura di parlare in pubblico
neanche tanti complimenti
Questa è una ricerca del 2017 un'altra
ricerca più recente del Regno Unito ci
dice che
nelle hit parade delle paure al primo
posto troviamo la paura delle altezze al
secondo posto la paura di parlare in
pubblico e al terzo posto la paura dei
Serpenti Beh sorprendente che la paura
di parlare in pubblico è all'interno è
in mezzo a due eventi che hanno a che
fare col pericolo di vita
beh
In effetti
se anche voi vi siete trovati in questa
situazione
vi ricorderete che non è così tanto
rassicurante Essere esposti al giudizio
del pubblico
mani sudate
fiato corto aumento della frequenza
cardiaca frequenta respiratoria farfalle
nello stomaco gambe cedevoli
insomma la paura di parlare in pubblico
è più che legittima è normale
Io ho sempre avuto paura di parlare in
pubblico
Ma l'evento peggiore
che io ricordi
risale al dicembre del 1999
a quell'epoca io ero la responsabile
della formazione di un importante
azienda automobilistica e mi accingevo a
fare una presentazione davanti al
consiglio di amministrazione al
presidente all'amministratore delegato
di cui aveva una paura folle era la mia
prima volta
bene Io ricordo quell'esperienza
terribile perché iniziai girata
completamente sulla slide
la leggevo una velocità sostenuta per
cercare di fare il più presto possibile
e le mani erano trattenute dietro legate
in modo sostenuto per evitare di
sbracciare e farmi vedere un po'
impacciata Ma come se tutto ciò non
fosse abbastanza il tacco destro mi
rimase infilato in una bastarda grata
nel pavimento e si staccò
e quindi dovetti Cercare di mantenere
l'equilibrio la voce nel finire quella
terribile esecuzione e al termine mi
girai
vidi che il pubblico non era molto
interessato fece un grande respiro di
sollievo raccolsi il tacco la dignità e
tornai al posto con una convinzione non
avrei mai più voluto fare un'esperienza
del genere
e in effetti dopo una partenza così 1-2
domande se le fa E siccome non avevo le
risposte ho continuato a farmele oggi
vorrei condividere con voi cinque cose
che credo di avere capito vi parlerò
delle cinque paure legate al parlare in
pubblico e fortunatamente a 5 modi
possibili per poterci convivere
la prima paura
è quella di guardare il pubblico mi
capita spesso oratori che iniziano la
loro presentazione quando ancora c'è il
titolo e presentandosi guardando la
slide e iniziando questa relazione
solipsistica con la slide In effetti la
adorano ci hanno passato le note la
36esima release
guardare il pubblico è il più importante
canale di contatto che noi possiamo
aprire è un invito a venire con voi
e in effetti non guardare il pubblico
autorizza il pubblico a fare lo stesso
Se ci pensate è frustrante guardare
qualcuno che non ci guarda
a volte però guardare la slide
Ci evita di vedere tutti questi occhi
che avete puntato addosso
perché ciò che ci terrorizza del parlare
in pubblico è il pubblico stesso è
quell'ansia quella aspettativa quel
silenzio
Obama diceva Guarda a una Guarda a una
persona alla volta e il pubblico svanirà
io lo trovo un consiglio piuttosto
interessante
E anche lo sguardo è importante e
l'espressione con cui noi ci presentiamo
davanti a un pubblico
l'espressione è contagiosa
dobbiamo necessariamente essere seri
certo essere seri un bel biglietto da
visita si parla di seri professionisti e
non di spassosi professionisti ma il
rischio è essendo l'espressione
contagiosa che io mi voglio far
percepire seria davanti a voi e a loro
assumo questa espressione triste
e dopo un po' davanti a me Io vedo
persone molto tristi e dico Caspita che
faccio e che hanno qua davanti e
probabilmente la morale che al termine
usciremo tutti un po' più depressi Io
non sto dicendo che bisogna avere quel
sorriso ad ogni costo abbiamo fatto
almeno 20 per cento quest'anno ma almeno
all'inizio
in cui il pubblico decide anche se
guardarvi come guardarvi può essere
utile anche a voi perché sorridere
rilassa una serie di muscoli facciali e
del collo e trasmette al pubblico che
tra le tante cose brutte che mi potevano
capitare oggi pomeriggio quella di
essere con voi non è proprio la peggiore
la seconda paura è quella di sembrare
impacciati
perché quando uno è davanti a un
pubblico
ha un insight e si rende conto di avere
le mani e le braccia
E allora cerca di trovare quella
posizione che gli consente di sembrare
un po' più comodo e rilassato
il consiglio è quello di partire con le
braccia lungo i fianchi in una posizione
di folle per poi utilizzarle per
sottolineare enfatizzare i concetti che
stiamo dicendo a voce magari in modo
coerente è una grande opportunità è una
grande opportunità non passa può essere
percepita al contrario vi parlerò di a e
di B toccheremo Tre temi 1 2 e 3 aiuta a
sottolinea certo le mani a volte
scaricano tensioni e potrebbe essere che
si facciano gesti inconsulti allora
magari tenere un oggetto coerente in
mano non una banana ma per esempio un
avanzatore aiuta a scaricare tensione
anche la penna evitando però questa cosa
che come dire se l'avete tenete la ferma
perché vi state creando un distrattore
essere impacciati non è solo legato alle
mani e le braccia anche la postura può
comunicare in pace e io mi chiedo perché
certe persone devono partire già in una
situazione di difficoltà in una
posizione che non ti dà del Benessere
quindi avere i piedi larghi quanto le
anche ti consente di avere una postura
più equilibrata e
lo trasmette anche a chi hai davanti
chiaramente se non avete perso un sacco
ma da questa postura poi noi Possiamo
anche decidere di muoverci perché anche
muoverci può aiutarci a scaricare
tensione e quindi so che devo stare in
questo cerchio Ma se io mi continuo a
muovere in questo modo diventa un po' un
ritmo e la signora con la maglia a righe
Probabilmente tra un po' mi vorrebbe
sparare come all'orso nel circo quindi
muoversi va bene ma poi fermiamoci
perché altrimenti diventano ritmi
costanti che si trasmettono come
l'espressione e infastidiscono e sono
molto potenti non Ci credete
allora Vi pregherei di fare a
te
attenzione
a Come state respirando
i ritmi passano al di sotto della
consapevolezza razionale e sono molto
potenti hanno la possibilità di fare
stare bene o male il vostro pubblico
perché se non Respirate state male
e su questo mi collego alla terza paura
che quella di non essere coinvolgente
con la voce
con la voce Noi diamo musicalità al
nostro discorso aiutiamo le persone a
capire le pause a respirare con noi a
sentire la parte importante del discorso
Intendo dire che se non usiamo bene la
voce non rischiamo di essere solo più
noiosi ma anche meno comprensibili
la voce di fatto non è predefinita e la
possiamo imparare a modularla per essere
più coinvolgenti i punti su cui possiamo
lavorare sono il primo il volume
il volume è l'ampiezza del suono
diamo importanza alle cose dette con un
volume alto
ma diamo altresì importanza alle cose
dette con un volume piano la cosa
importante è variare il volume per
evitare quell'effetto ottavor linea
piatta che creerebbe un po' di
sonnolenza il secondo elemento è il tono
che è la frequenza del suono e
vado a grave
tendiamo a considerare come più
credibile
un messaggio detto con voce grave bassa
e tendiamo
a Pergine con voce acuta
la signora Thatcher aveva una voce molto
acuta e gracchiante e quindi si fece
ripulire concorsi di fonetica il suo
tono perché dava un'immagine di donna
molto forte e passiamo al terzo che è il
ritmo
vi sarà capitato di sentire persone che
quando parlavano
avevano un ritmo
abbastanza calmo e voi non sapete perché
ma un pochino vi sentivate una certa
sono lenza Oppure quelle persone che
quando parlano non si sa per quale
motivo ma vi fanno aumentare la
frequenza cardiaca
Oppure quelle persone che respirano a
casaccio come il primo esempio di ritmo
che vi ho fatto Noi ascoltiamo con più
interesse le cose dette lentamente
e diamo meno interesse le cose dette
molto velocemente a un medicinale usare
con cautela
Allora quando faccio questo questa
battuta le persone a volte fanno una
stranequazione Ah sì Allora io adesso le
cose te le dico così no
non stavo intendendo questo
il consiglio è di parlare a una velocità
che vi consenta di articolare bene le
parole e di non mangiarvele e di
soffermarvi laddove volete sottolineare
un concetto
avendo cura di spingere leggermente sul
finale delle parole per evitare quelle
quei suoni
parassiti che ti fanno dire dillo Ti
prego dillo che sono le sospensioni
prosodiche che danno un po' l'idea di
uno che non sa bene quello che sta
dicendo
il quarto punto è la paura di bloccarsi
o fare scena muta
prima di una preparazione prima di una
presentazione Bisogna prepararsi
ed evitare di andare a braccio
Grazie Simona per averci dato questo
consiglio che prima di una presentazione
Bisogna prepararsi è davvero molto
interessante è vero banale ma spesso
sottovalutato
cercare di prepararsi 5 nuclei tematici
prepararsi l'inizio e la fine aiutare a
memorizzare questa
Questi elementi ci può aiutare a
sentirci un po' più a nostro agio Poi
ogni tanto accade che ci facciamo
qualche domanda del tipo E se mi blocco
e se faccio scena muta E se mi fanno
proprio quella domanda e se divento
rosso e se mi impappino e se mi trema la
voce
Chi di voi si è mai posto Ha avuto mai
questi pensieri prima di una
presentazione
Ok bene siamo in buona compagnia
Ok
avere la consapevolezza di questi
pensieri negativi ci può aiutare un
pochino a gestirli io utilizzo il
respiro
perché il respiro è qualcosa che abbiamo
sempre a portata di mano e ci aiuta a
tornare più centrati e quindi prima di
una presentazione
dedicare cinque minuti ad inspirare ed
espirare
inspirare ed espirare può allentare un
pochino la presa di questi pensieri
ci può far sentire un po' meglio come
stiamo con il corpo e se sentiamo delle
tensioni nervose magari ci rilassiamo
proviamo a rilassarle
questo ci consentirà non solo di essere
più
consapevoli di essere più questo
allenamento ci consentirà di essere più
attenti E concentrati in quello che
stiamo dicendo e libererà anche spazio
nella memoria
infine l'ultima paura che è quella di
non essere esaustivi è quella del tipo
anche questa importante anche questo è
importante e mi capita
spesso di vedere slide come questa
dove l'oratore magari ci dite ci dice
come vedete il dato del primo
quadrimestre la gente si guarda e dice
no un carattere 10 non lo leggiamo
oppure abbiamo oratori che lo ammettono
e dicono il dato del primo quadrimestre
voi non lo leggete Ma io ve lo commento
che Allora uno si dice ma perché non me
lo fai uscire carattere 35 sottolineato
in giallo mi dà la possibilità di
vederlo oppure oratori che passano
praticamente scrivono tutto nella slide
tutto tutto e Loro leggono esattamente
tutto quello che c'è scritto e
praticamente la loro presenza è inutile
Inoltre Noi leggiamo a voce alta ad una
velocità di 120 parole al minuto Chi
legge a voce bassa legge a 180 e ha
Giusto quello scarto per dire Ma se mi
mandavi la presentazione me la facevo
per i fatti miei
la presentazione e quindi le slide sono
di supporto al pubblico
non all'oratore non sono i bigliettini
che ci facevamo al liceo per copiare in
pace durante l'esame
allora
Che cosa può essere rilevante il fatto
che noi ricordiamo davvero pochi
concetti dopo una presentazione sono
davvero pochi i concetti che ci
rimangono in mente allora
e vi dirò in più che non dipende tanto
dalla capacità dell'oratore rimangono
sempre pochi allora qual è la differenza
tra un bravo rotore e un cattivo oratore
il bravo oratore questa cosa la sa e
quindi preparerà e avrà ben chiaro Quali
sono i cinque concetti più importanti
che vuole che il suo pubblico ricordi e
se non lo riuscirà a fare lui di trovare
cinque concetti che conosce l'argomento
come potrà il pubblico capire davvero
quei 5
ricordarseli a distanza di tempo
e quindi 5 è un numero importante
5 sono anche le tappe di questo breve
viaggio insieme
e al di là del viaggio e alla fine del
viaggio alla fine della paura questi
piccoli suggerimenti e semplici possono
aiutarci almeno a sopravvivere davanti a
un pubblico